And yeah, just one
Do you want me to like
You'll get a roar and filtered bullets
Good okay, you gotta test our abs to see if you understand the tusks, okay?
Okay
Of adding a new recruit expense and splitting it amongst the household members
So add a new expense and then split it. Yep. Okay, so we'll go to the ad expense button. That's in the bottom
Yeah, and it will come up
Enter the name. Is this the name for the expense? Yep
Is there cheese great?
Try to follow the details rent
Mm-hmm 1200
The baby is 31st of May
repeat weekly
31st of May
It's coming up as different values
Try to click again, it's not interactable
Oh
Yeah, it's coming up with cheese and then hello and in
Just keep going yeah repeat
Did you want to weekly repeat sweet and then split with everybody wasn't it? Oh three three. Yeah, sweet
So all of them
And then create the expense using the button down here
Okay, it's coming up is there wasn't anything there it's a good era
Letting me know
So we wanted it for rent
the immense
1200 okay, it's coming up as 10 and in the repeat was weekly
And we want it to be with Sam as well because we want it to be split with three people, let's see what happens
a
Very funky blue cheese so flat true
Okay, I'm assuming that the name
Okay, try well maybe I can exit out and yeah, let's try again let's go at expense
We're entering the name
Cheese still
Yeah, and we go ran into the amount is there it's coming up as hello
Oh
Sure
weekly
Description
Let's try and create it. Okay, it's coming up with an error here. Let's try again
Rinse inter amount is 10 select values weekly
Okay
Creating itself
Don't quite know what's up with that. Okay. Okay, we move in next
It just wouldn't create an expense it would when
the first values were entered
It would then give error messages saying some of the values were blank
Even though they were filled out and then on filling them out again
Clicking the create expense button would just not do something. I wouldn't do anything
Okay, we move to the second task
The second test is to ensure the functionality of payment and existing expense
And verify it removed from the list. Okay, so we're paying an expense. I want to go into the pay up section
And I will guess pay the click the pay button, okay
Open
Alex and you select the power the power cool. Yeah, I'm here. I see the Alex categories
I see the power I will click pay their pay for power. Yes
It is now disappeared from the list and I imagine if I go to home. Yeah
Okay
Okay, the next task is to confirm the ability to view past expense and verify payment history, okay payment
So there's an expenses tab. This is going into yeah, I can see the history from today
The past week and the past month. Okay. Yeah, so you had to locate
Garbage garbage and verify the detail who paid the coverage for that. Okay, so garbage was paid in the past week
$380, you know, it was paid by person one and person two on the 27th of May. Okay, sweet
The next task is to
Verify the inside features for the rent category and ensure equity data visualization
Okay, so we'll go into the insights tab. I can see a very nice pie chart here. Yeah
We've got the top categories for rent, which is indeed the top category power is next. Yeah, then it should be broadband
Yep, and food and other. Yeah. Yeah, so I want you to
Click the event category. The rent category is being clicked. I now have a bar chart with the week. Okay
So you had to view the monthly the monthly I now have the bar chart with four values on it
It was paid consistently it seems with consistent rent. So they're all the same value. Yep, all 450. Yep. Looks good
Okay, your next step is to test the customization option for display and accessibility
ensure
Usability for all users. Okay, so that will probably be in the three bar menu. I'm thinking we're going in here
probably app settings
And we wanted to do
accessibility
Which isn't quite here, but it's probably on the display. Yes
And then there's dark mode system and different contrasts so we wanted accessibility
So let's say we go colorblind friendly. It does indeed change the colors
Okay
Yeah, and it stays as you go through that. Yep. I
Want you to try other?
Accessibility see what you see. Okay, let's go back into
Display so there's the dark mode. Yeah, that works nicely. We've got high contrast which does that as well?
The system do something. I
imagine
All works well
Okay, your last time is to help test the help and support spontaneity
Open support ensuring user can find information and contact support if needed perfect
That will again probably be in the three bar menu help and supports right there. Good. It's not showing as interactable
Try app setting app settings if we go into absent. Yep. Okay. There is a helping sport thing in app settings
That could be one thing to just have as a little issue
It's in two different places
So we'd want to contact support
Yeah, and then we'd want to fill out our information
Our email the message that we have and then we could send it and it comes up with the confirmation
No, it was all very intuitive yeah, no, it was easy to move around the buttons made sense
There was good contrast with the interactable areas
I
Didn't have to second-guess myself on anything it all made sense to use
The only thing that kind of went wrong was just a figma issue which the figma was better
I imagine it wouldn't have gone wrong in the first place and it would have worked as it was intended
So I didn't really have any negative feedback to give
Okay, what about us one any?
Yeah expense one the expense stuff made sense
But I had coated you know, yeah, that's just the figma thing it'll kind of make sense to use
Good functionalities in there you had your history with all the information
Yeah, I like the bear with the variety you guys have in there
I think the the traversal options you have is good. I like the tabs
Did I see that it was part of it was swipeable and some like that
Yeah, so you've got some swipe functionality which I think is really cool
That like yet you've got good headers you've got all that it's all in there
Yeah, okay. Okay. Thank you. Thank you